Vajillion pipes.
Looks good.
Got lots of power.
Rolling all over the place.
Okay.
We've got the dehumidifying and the 24 volts shorted to each other, so that should be working.
We've got this.
And we've got...
Oh, that's funny, I didn't realize.
Okay, well, I heard a click.
It's good, I guess.
and then this pump which doesn't look like anything's actually attached to it and kind of the point is for the pump to get things out what's
going on on this side what's going on over here okay but we've got okay so it seems like is
the pump just not being used at all maybe uh but it's missing yeah we've got these two bare wires also
It looks like it's just connected directly.
Then the question is why is it not on?
I don't think the breaker got tripped.
I hear a little click right there.
Same, click, click.
I would have assumed that's the right way to turn it for a dryer.
I'm just noting, okay, we've got that going into the side.
And I'll try to go back down.